♪ (hymne national ukrainien) ♪
- La foule entonne l'hymne
national du pays pour accuei
leurs soeurs, leurs mères,
enfin... On réconforte
La mère d'Olena, après des
semaines d'angoisse, arrive
enfin.r.r.r.r.r.r.r.r.r.r.r.r.r.
Des larmes coulent,
une paix s'installe.
Cette jeune Ukrainienne est
fébrile à l'idée de commencer
Plusieurs ressortissants
seront hébergés par des familles
d'accueil.
Maria n'y croit toujours pas.
Après toute cette attente,
Anastasia et sa fille
sont enfin au Québsurer ces noux
arrivants, le ministre Boulet
a tenu à les rencontrer.
JEAN BOULET, min. Immigration,
Francisat important pour moi
de leur dire bienvenue au nom
des Québécois et de leur faire
comprendre qu'on allait
s'occuper d'eux, indépendamms.
- C'est le deuxième vol nolisé
organisé par Ottawa d'une
série de trois.
Plus de 120 000 Ukrainienseeeeee
d'autorisation de voyage
e Canada-Ukraine,
mais seulement 35 000 sont
arrivées au Canada.
des Affaires étrangères
- C'est sûr qu'on doit faire
mieux. En même temps,
on fait déjà beaucoup.ttent
l'aéroport vers leur prochain
défi : créer leur nouvelle vie.
Comme Natalia, arrivée au pays
il y a trois semaiaux meubleauxr
une nouvelle vie; toute
une expérience pour Charlotte,
qui l'accueille.CHARLOTTE FRAMB,
famille d'accueil
- C'est pas juste comme...
ils viennent puis ils sont en
avec eux à travers une étape
importan vie puis
ça touche à notre intimité
et à la leur.
et respecter les limites
de tous, ajoute-t- ajoute-t- aj.
- C'est intéressant de penser
combien de temps est-ce
quelle condition on aimerait
accueillt on aimerait
aider...
- Natalia est reconnaissante.
nous. Charlotte est une femme
formidable", dit-elle.
Une expérience qui restera
gravée dans la mémoire
de générosité.
Marie-Josée Paquette-Comeau,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.